dans mon costume le moins adapté à TED.
Il y avait un acte connu sous le nom d'« acte de l'oracle ».
Dans l'acte de l'oracle, des membres du public,
je sais que vous l'avez fait aussi,
écrivaient des questions secrètes,
le genre de questions que vous poseriez à un voyant,
scellaient cette question dans une enveloppe
et sur l'extérieur de l'enveloppe, ils écrivaient leurs initiales
ainsi qu'approximativement où ils étaient assis dans le public.
Puis l'oracle, le télépathe, prenait les enveloppes une à une,
ne les ouvrait pas,
mais il essayait de deviner la question scellée à l'intérieur.
S'il trouvait la question,
il essayait aussi d'y répondre pour la personne.
L'acte s'est propagé comme une traînée de poudre.
C'est, je pense, un testament au charme séduisant
d'une personnalité puissante vous offrant des réponses faciles, simples
aux questions et anxiétés complexes et subtiles de la vie.
Je veux remercier ceux ayant écrit des questions.
Je ne les ai pas vues, quelqu'un les surveille.
Merci beaucoup.
Je vais les prendre. Merci à tous ceux qui l'ont fait.
Je devrais probablement dire deux ou trois choses avant de commencer.
En toute honnêteté,
je ne peux pas voir à travers les enveloppes.
Ce sont d'épaisses enveloppes noires et scellées.
Vous le saurez, je ne peux pas voir à travers.
C'est important, je ne connais aucun d'entre vous
et personne ne joue de rôle.
Ce n'est pas ainsi.
Troisièmement ...
Je ne crois pas une seconde avoir de dons psychologiques particuliers,
encore moins de dons psychiques.
Commençons.
Non.
(Rires)
D'accord, celle-ci --
Oh, sympa.
Celle-ci est intéressante. Il y en a quelques-unes.
Je vais commencer avec celle-ci.
Celle-là est intéressante car l'écriture ondule.
Elle monte et descend
ce qui normalement signifie, mais pas toujours,
que la personne ne connaît pas la réponse à la question,
c'est donc normalement une question sur l'avenir.
Cela suggère de l'incertitude.
Je dirais que c'est une demoiselle,
pour l'âge, c'est difficile à dire avec cette écriture minimale,
mais je dirais peut-être la trentaine ou la quarantaine, découvrons-le.
C'est écrit -- et une question sur l'avenir --
c'est écrit : « JN, centre ».
C'est quelqu'un de cette vaste section centrale.
Si vous pensez que c'est vous, pourriez-vous vous manifester ?
J'ai du mal à voir le centre.
Bonjour, faites-nous signe.
Alors J ...
Jane ? Jessica ?
Jessica : Oui.
Derren Brown : Lequel ? Jessica : Jessica.
DB : Merci. Juste une supposition. Un faible murmure d'approbation, merci ?
(Rires)
Je prends.
Jessica, je ne demanderai pas votre âge,
mais est-ce une question sur l'avenir ?
Jessica : Mhm ? DB : Oui ?
Jessica : Oui. DB : Oui. OK.
Qu'avons-nous demandé ?
Qu'a demandé Jessica au sujet de l'avenir ?
Ai-je raison si je dis aux alentours de la quarantaine ?
Jessica : Je prends.
(Rires)
DB : C'est important
car nous posons des questions différentes selon notre âge.
Répétez : « Je prends. »
Jessica : Je prends.
DB : Virginie ? Vous êtes de Virginie ?
Jessica : Oui.
DB : Oui. Alors --
(Rires)
Je crois que c'est une demoiselle,
je crois que c'est une demoiselle qui veut quitter la Virginie.
Je crois que vous considérez des projets,
il s'agit de savoir si les choses vont s'aligner pour votre départ.
Montrez-moi vos mains.
L'autre côté que je vois les ongles ?
Je pense que vous avez une ferme
et qu'il s'agit de savoir si vous allez vendre cette ferme et partir de Virginie.
Est-ce correct ?
Jessica : Absolument, c'est la question.
DB : Très bien. Génial. Merci. C'est une super question !
Quelle était la question ? Qu'avez-vous écrit ?
Jessica : « Vendrai-je la ferme en Virginie ? »
DB : Vendrez-vous la ferme ?
C'est une super question si vous prétendez être un voyant
car il s'agit de l'avenir
donc je peux vous répondre par oui ou par non.
Ça ne signifie rien. Vous ne pouvez pas le vérifier.
Et c'est dangereux --
si je réponds oui ou non, cela vous restera dans la tête
et cela ne peut pas ne pas influencer vos décisions.
C'est dangereux, cependant --
(Rires)
Je pense que vous vendrez la ferme
car vous êtes le genre de personne
qui obtiendra ce qu'elle veut.
Je pense que quand on souhaite quelque chose, on se concentre dessus
au détriment d'autres choses
sur lesquelles on devrait plus se concentrer,
êtes-vous d'accord ?
Éduquée, vous avez passé quelques années en --
Dites oui de nouveau, le mot « oui » ? Jessica : Oui.
DB : Non ? Jessica : Non.
DB : En Californie ? A Berkeley ? C'est une supposition.
Jessica : Je suis allée à Berkeley. Arrêtez de faire ça !
DB : C'est donc un oui.
Et vous êtes allée en Inde récemment.
Il y a là un tout petit quelque chose. Oui ? Non ?
Jessica : Oui, je viens de revenir d'Inde.
DB : Pour moi c'est oui, je ne veux pas dire que c'est écrit
car ça ne l'est pas et vous devez en prendre la responsabilité.
DB : Asseyez-vous. Merci. Faisons-en un autre.
(Applaudissements)
AH, également au centre ? AH.
Ça va être un homme, un peu plus âgé, proche de la cinquantaine je dirais.
AH au centre, levez-vous si vous pensez que c'est vous.
AH. Bonjour, peut-on lui apporter un micro ?
Aussi vite que possible, que la caméra soit sur lui.
Oh, regardez cela ! Ne bougez pas. Ne bougez pas.
Restez complètement immobile.
Êtes-vous debout ? Où êtes-vous ?
Homme : Je suis debout. Je suis petit.
DB : OK.
Vous avez changé ça.
Vous avez fait quelque chose en vous levant.
Oui ou non, avez-vous écrit quelque chose --
vous ne le faites plus mais l'avez fait en vous levant --
qui a à voir avec votre pied ou votre jambe gauche, oui ou non ?
Homme : Oui.
DB : Très bien. Il nous donnait un signal très clair en se levant.
Mettez votre poids sur votre côté gauche et dites « oui ».
Homme : Oui.
DB : Ôtez votre main de la poche, mettez votre poids sur l'autre côté,
changez le micro de main et redites « oui ».
Homme : Oui.
DB : Vous avez une dislocation
du gros orteil du côté gauche ?
Homme : Oui.
DB : Merci beaucoup. Super. C'était bien. Asseyez-vous, asseyez-vous.
Puis-je avoir le micro ? Je vais changer de micro pour ceci.
Puis-je avoir un micro ? Merci.
Merci beaucoup. Ici ça serait super.
Je vais changer de micro car --
j'espère que vous m'entendez toujours ?
Je vais me bander les yeux.
Je le fais pour ne pas avoir d'indices quand vous vous levez.
Je ne peux pas voir où vous mettez vos mains,
comment vous réagissez à ce que je dis,
ce que les gens autour de vous font.
S'ils connaissent la réponse à la question, c'est toujours utile.
Je n'aurai pas tous ces avantages,
mais étrangement,
cela me libère
et je veux que cela vous libère aussi
alors si vous n'avez rien écrit
mais auriez aimé le faire,
vous pouvez participer.
L'objectif en écrivant la question est simplement d'obtenir
une formulation claire et succincte dans votre tête.
Si vous pouvez trouver une question dans votre tête
et la rendre claire et succincte, envoyez-la moi
et je vais essayer de faire cela sans avoir rien d'écrit.
Commencez à former des questions mais envoyez-moi aussi votre nom.
« Mon nom est », le nom du gars,
et « qu'est-ce que mon pied a de bizarre » ou quelle qu'ait été la question.
Un nom et une question.
Il y a déjà quelqu'un, je suppose que vous êtes devant
car votre nom est assez clair.
J'ai l'impression que vous êtes devant au milieu.
Laissez-moi... Allan ?
J'ai l'impression que c'est Allan.
Vous allez être plutôt devant et vers le centre, je pense.
J'ai l'impression que cela vient de là.
Il y a un homme, vers la soixantaine, quelque chose comme ça.
Allan : Oui.
DB : Vous avez un micro ? Super, merci.
Allan, dites « stop » quand j'arrive à vous
que je sache où vous êtes,
vers où me tourner.
Allan : Stop.
DB : Êtes-vous capricorne ? Allan : Oui.
DB : Allan a quelque chose en tête.
Avez-vous entendu la réserve dans sa voix ?
Cela va être quelque chose de très délicat.
Je pense qu'avec vous... Redites « oui » pour moi ?
Allan : Oui.
DB : Cela va être soit --
non, ce n'est pas ça.
C'est un accès, c'est un mot de passe ou un accès à quelque chose.
Oui ou non, avez-vous quelque chose avec un mot de passe en tête ?
Allan : Oui.
DB : Un mot de passe d'ordinateur ?
DB : Excellent !
(Rires)
Dans ce cas, je finirai là-dessus. Laissez-moi --
Si je fais bien les choses,
tout le public le connaîtra ainsi que des millions de gens.
Vous le changerez, n'est-ce pas ?
Allan : Bien sûr.
(Rires)
DB : Répétez « bien sûr » ? Allan : Bien sûr.
DB : Si c'est un mot -- j'imagine que c'est un mot --
visualisez le mot de passe écrit devant vous
en grandes lettres majuscules
et, en le regardant, pensez pour moi à une lettre vers le milieu,
ne la dites pas à voix haute,
ayez une lettre dans votre tête qui est au milieu.
Vous en avez une ? Allan : Oui.
DB : Tenez-vous y.
Vous avez changé, OK.
Vous avez changé d'avis.
Vous vous êtes arrêté sur --
je pense que c'est un « B », oui ?
Allan : Non.
Non, ce n'est pas ça.
DB : Alors c'est un « I » ? Allan : Correct.
DB : Mais vous aviez un B. Allan : Oui.
DB : Il a changé d'avis. Il a changé d'avis.
(Rires)
Je le vois écris là.
Continuez à vous le répéter dans votre tête.
Vous jouez de la batterie, non ?
Allan : Oui.
DB : Sortez-vous cela de la tête, sortez-vous cela de la tête,
concentrez-vous seulement sur ce truc pour moi ;
(Rires)
Mon boulot est de vous vendre une histoire.
J'essaye de le faire pour vous tous, que vous prêtiez attention
à la chose que je veux que vous trouviez importante,
que vous ignoriez ce que je veux que vous ignoriez,
que vous reliez ces éléments narratifs
pour vous raconter une histoire sur ce que je fais
et cela marche car nous sommes des créatures créant des histoires,
nous le faisons au quotidien.
Nous nous promenons dans ce monde complexe et subtil
plein de gens complexes et subtils comme vous et moi, Allan,
et nous les réduisons à ces personnages soignés
qui collent à l'histoire que nous nous racontons :
« Elle n'est pas sûre d'elle », « Il est arrogant »,
« Ils ne sont pas dignes de confiance ».
Ce ne sont que des histoires,
comme l'histoire selon laquelle je peux lire dans vos pensées.
En ce moment, vous pensez aussi à vendre votre entreprise, non ?
Allan : Correct.
DB : Qui a à voir avec la peau ?
Allan : Oui.
DB : Les soins de la peau.
Allan : Euh, oui.
La raison pour laquelle j'adore faire cela
est que cela me rappelle d'essayer d'être plus en vie et attentif
à la complexité et à la subtilité de ce qui est réel,
il se passe toujours des choses que nous ignorons
et cela signifie que nous pouvons être moins coincés, plus gentils
car nous reconnaissons qu'il y a de la peur derrière leur stress
et qu'une réponse défensive n'est pas nécessaire,
nous pouvons voir les histoires pour ce qu'elles sont
et reconnaître que la vie, il ne s'agit pas que de nous.
Oh !
Votre mot de passe. Où êtes-vous ? Où est-il ?
Allan : Juste là.
DB : Levez-vous. Votre mot de passe est « ariboy ».
A-r-i-b-o-y ? Est-ce correct ? Allan : C'est correct.
DB : Merci beaucoup. Merci beaucoup.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)